only on CBS this morning guess what
Oprah's here in studio 57 why she's
going to reveal her new book club
selection
she's in the middle of her 20/20 vision
your life InFocus tour promoting
wellness all around the country for
special guests so far have included in
Schumer Lady gaga there's more to come
with Dwayne Johnson Tina Fey was there
first lady Michelle Obama and actress
Tracee Ellis Ross also coming up so
during her recent tour stop in North
Carolina last weekend comedian Amy
Schumer was on stage with Oprah to talk
about being a new mom and I heard that
one of your takeaways from all of this
was that women are just warriors we are
warriors all of us I mean for real that
is what I learned
I didn't just learn how strong I was I
really learned as a whole how strong
women are and you know men are great too
and like that's awesome and you guys can
like throw a touchdown but like can you
make a baby
Oprah joins is at the table listen I was
thinking about you for the Delta story
about the CEO I know two months is
extraordinary
I started out giving a week's pay I
remember that because when I had my very
first job in television my first boss
Herald Crump called us up and gave us a
week's pay for Christmas and so I did
that every year after 22 months we have
a lot to talk to you about where we're
gonna start with because you've been
making news lately about the documentary
and boy I try not to make news okay I
know for told me last night we had
dinner and she said if if I didn't have
this book club I would have called in
sick today who called in sick but I do
think it's important for people to hear
from you personally for you to address
it I know that you've released a
statement because you decided to take
your name off the documentary involving
Russell Simmons and his alleged abuse of
women and I think people question why
would Oprah of all people do that well
first of all I just want to say that I
have lived me too since I was nine years
old and was raped at nine sexually
assaulted from nine to 14 and then
raped again at 14 and nothing is harder
than standing up for yourself when
you're 14 and not being believed and I
was not believed by my own family so I
stand in support of these women I
believe them it was a hard decision
because I knew that Russell Simmons had
started publicly pressuring me and that
me pulling out of the documentary was
going to look like I was being pressured
so what he publicly and publicly and
privately yes yes and so what do I say
to that is for me and Gail knows this in
all experiences of my life and
particularly when I'm in a crisis the
only question for me is what is the
right thing to do for you for me and so
before the public pressure had started
before Russell had gone with his
Instagram I had gone to the to the
filmmakers and I had said to them
Houston I think we have a problem here
because new information had come forward
the very first time this was announced
and I said I think we need to pull out
of Sundance and if we can't pull out of
Sundance I'm gonna have to take my name
off I don't want to have to take my name
off because it's going to be a big hole
Sundance so we can get it right that's
because I don't care about awards I
don't care I just care about getting it
right and I think there's some
inconsistencies and the stories that we
need Russell Simmons says has first of
all he's denied all of the allegations
vigorously yeah you again have said that
you want to quickly support these women
yes why are you making it a point to say
that even though you're withdrawing from
the because I believe that the women's
voices deserve to be heard and as an
executive producer I also was in a
position where I thought some things
were not right I wanted the context of
the story to be broadened I wanted more
women brought into the story and I will
say this that I thought Michelle Miller
story last week with with with with
three of the women one of the women had
just been added Alexian Norton's Norton
Norton strong I think is her name and I
had asked that more women be added when
you see the documentary which I do hope
people will see the documentary I felt
that story needed to be brought and one
of the things I said to the producers is
I don't think that deserves to just be a
soundbite and I can honestly say that I
learned more about Alexia Norton strong
in Michelle Miller story than I did in
the duck so I was asking for changes and
let me just say this I've been an
executive producer since the beginning
of the Oprah Show and there were many
times when you know people are saying
what's the time line until the thing is
on the screen you have the right to
change your mind and make changes and I
remember many times on the show
particularly there was a Columbine story
we were going to run for the 10th
anniversary and the night before I
pulled it because something about it
didn't feel right and I thought we are
gonna cause more school school shootings
if we put this on the air so I've always
been in the position as an executive
producer if I say I want changes usually
those are done so what this has taught
me is don't put your name on anything
that you do not have creative creative
control over but some people have
perceived this as a victory for Russell
you know it's not a victory for Russell
and I unequivocally say that I did not
pull out because of Russell this is not
a victory lap for him I cannot be
silenced by a Russell Simmons after all
I've been through and also you know I
spent three years on trial trying to
protect the girls at my school who had
accused a dorm parent of sexual assault
three years on trial and nobody believed
them but over it struck me as odd that
some would accuse you of not standing up
for women and black women in particular
I know it's ridiculous ridiculous and
also ridiculous to think that I could be
intimidated by Russell Simmons yeah or
anyone think anyone not at this point
I'm about to turn 6666
hard you know and people who were saying
that I was silenced or came out because
I'm a son I thought I'm not silence I'm
sitting on CBS this morning which is
exactly the opposite of being silence so
I stand with the women I support the
women and you know I do hope people will
see the film even though deceive and
make their own decisions about it
you